so I think that Spirit of enjoying the
unexpected wacky things that were
happening at the table is what we took
into the movie and so we kept working to
surprise each other sounds lovely quite
the opposite I know I was being ironic I
find irony as a blade because he who
wields it most especially you're not a
lot of fun are you
yeah zinc is the ultimate paletin he's
ridiculously heroic painfully righteous
and these are your words yeah no I
recognize them
seem to have an all-around good guy
complete opposite from your recent role
in the gray men which was more fun to
play like the hero or the bad boy the
joy of both of them is that they're very
uncompromising men
um they will do what is necessary to
achieve what they want and I think I
like plugging into that about both
characters I think that there is a Glee
to being both that evil and that Goods
they're not as dissimilar as you might
think I think evil might be slightly
more fun uh but good might be slightly
more satisfying I think there's
something very very satisfying about
being able to hold your ground as the
literal Knight and shining armor that
Zen cares with his billowing heroic cape
and getting to then jump in and
literally slay dragons with your sword
like that's that's a real kick now think
seems like the kind of players to take
DNA D like way too seriously if you were
to actually play what's a DND play style
are you anything like that
I wish I could say no
um I think unfortunately uh John Daley's
already exposed me on this we played a
big game of guns and Dragons um as a
group before we started filming
um and because I've grown up playing
games a little bit similar to Dungeons
and Dragons I was ready like I knew the
mechanics I knew the rules and I jumped
in and uh John was like yeah reggae knew
what he was doing and he took it very
seriously which fed directly into the
character
um so I'm not sure I can deny that I
think the answer is that yes I'm a
little bit similar to that but I like to
think that I have a bit more fun I was
able to bounce off the wacky things like
Chris Pine was doing on my right
Michelle's on the other side of the
table and Sophia's turning into an eagle
every two seconds doing crazy things
um so I think that Spirit of enjoying
the unexpected wacky things that were
happening at the table is what we took
into the movie and so we kept working to
surprise each other and bring out things
that no one saw coming and if we were
laughing then hopefully you guys would
be laughing at home it was a really good
movie by the way thank you very much I
appreciate that I as Michelle was
question did like an hour ago but in
honorable leaves zinc in holga are like
the most physical fighters in a showdown
between the two who would win what did
Michelle say well I'll tell you after
you tell me your answer you know I gotta
back my boy zank I think zank would win
I don't think it would be an easy win I
think that zenks failure you know what
no I'm gonna change my answer zenk would
lose but because he let Holger win in
order to be honorable that is exactly
what Michelle said zinc would probably
let me win because I'm a girl
you serious
there we go we know our characters we
know how this works that's the headlight
now my last question is that Chris
Brown's character uh again has like a
one-sided dislike for zank before he
grudgingly grows to respect him
um what is it about their Dynamic that
works in this movie oh man I mean you'd
have to tell me I think it was it was a
joy on set to be able to work with how
sharp Chris is Chris is so quick
um and so in tune with what the movie
needs he's a great leader on set he's so
good at steering we're a scene needs to
land and what the energy on set will be
in that scene so it was just being able
to kind of lean into that and know that
whatever I threw out Chris would be able
to bounce off of whatever he threw at me
I'd be able to bounce back at him
um and so it's just it was just really
really good fun being able to play in
the way the actors do at that higher
level with Chris
foreign
[Music]